furious at crazy left-wing kovat
policies Elon Musk takes the so-called
red pill prompting right-wingers to
claim the Tesla Voss as a conservative
and left wingers to call him a Nazi but
they think everybody's a Nazi speaking
of which a left-wing Harvard professor
praises Nazi education policy
the ACLU American Civil Liberties Union
comes out swinging against civil
liberties and the mainstream media get
caught with their masks down red pills
for everybody I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
this is a red pill buffet
enjoy I know buffets aren't allowed
anymore amid covet but here they are I
would love to know in the comments
section what you would call your red
pill moment just like Elon Musk add over
the weekend what even is a red pill I
don't know it's a little bit of a
complicated question what would you say
your red pill moment is because Elon
Musk's just over the past few days he
tweeted out take the red pill and then
there's a little red rose emoji which
actually makes it a little bit confusing
exactly what he was saying what does the
red pill mean if you were to ask a
hundred people in a room he said what is
the red pill you might get a hundred
different answers if you asked
independent minded people you know not
conservative but not leftist maybe
they're they have some kind of confusing
views their left-wing on one thing right
way on another they would say that
taking the red pill is to think
independently if you ask a conservative
what does it mean to take the red pill
they'd say it's to become a conservative
to stop being a liberal or a leftist or
a progressive and if you were to ask a
left winger what is the red pill they
tell you it's a code word for Nazi and
they actually did when Ilan Muscat
weeded this out over the weekend
everybody just said Elon Musk is a Nazi
now he there was a blue checkmark Molly
Jong fast
who said Elan musk is a racist he's a
bigot it's anything you know that the
left has done this in recent years
they've said that a bunch of innocuous
symbols are code words for neo-nazis so
they did this to the okay hand symbol
they said that's actually now like a
secret Nazi symbol they did this to a
glass of milk that's now basically a
swastika and they're doing it to the red
pill which is a reference to the movie
The Matrix you know people are
forgetting that this red pill idea it's
not some dark recess of the internet you
know it's hidden on the hidden levels of
4chan it comes from the matrix and in
the matrix there is a choice presented
said you can take the red pill and
you can see reality as it is or you can
take the blue pill and you can remain in
the kind of matrix fantasies that I
think is the most basic definition when
you apply the red pill language to
politics it means giving up ideology
realizing that ideology is a lie and I
think this is why Elon Musk put that
little red rose there because the red
rose is another Twitter symbol that
refers explicitly to the Democratic
socialists of America so you see a lot
of very far left-wing accounts have the
little red rose picture just kind of odd
races take the red pill and then a
little red rose was it because Elan musk
doesn't know what that red rose means is
because he thought it was a red pill
instead of a red rose was he being
ironic or sarcastic what is he well on
the one hand on the one level the one
thing we know a LAN musk is really good
at is getting everybody to talk about
him he's one of the greatest marketers
of his age but on the other hand I think
there's actually some significance to it
maybe which is regardless of exactly
where you want to try to pinpoint me
down on the left or on the right or in
the middle take the red pill means
rejecting these ideological
categorizations it means most basically
recognizing that the official narrative
is wrong
it means preferring reality to theory
this is a big difference between the
right and the left on the right the
conservatives that are best
we prefer reality we don't really care
about how it works in theory we don't
need it there to be a big manifesto
about how things work as long as it
actually works and on the left they
don't care if things actually work they
don't care if American society basically
works pretty well they don't care if the
West has led to a lot of human
flourishing they want to know how it
works in theory
Elon Musk is not a typical Republican
Joe Rogan he's another one of these he's
not a typical Republican right Joe Rogan
was a Bernie bro as of two months ago or
something but now Joe Rogan is saying I
can't vote for Biden I might end up
voting for Trump and now the left is
very upset with him for this he's
resisting ideological categorization but
I think there are a lot of people like
Joe I mean obviously there a lot of
people like
rogon his show is one of the biggest
podcasts in the world I think there are
a lot of people like Elon Musk who were
a little bit more independent minded and
who were coming over more to the right
if this were 20 years ago 15 years ago
this were during the Bush era you might
see more independent minded people
leaning left but now they're heading in
the direction of the Republicans or the
Conservatives or Trump why it's because
they're questioning their assumptions
they're taking the red pill they're
preferring reality to this kind of
official story that permeates our whole
political lives that we've been told
that probably isn't all that true and
the people most responsible for doling
out those red pills it's not me
it's not some other conservative it's
not even Donald Trump it's the media
it's the mainstream media and the
mainstream media have sort of exposed
themselves because of Donald Trump he's
helped them along but they have done it
themselves when people realize that the
mainstream media apparatus are not
telling you the truth or telling you
lies or constructing whole narratives
out of whole cloth then that difference
between the ideology and the reality
becomes very very clear we will get to
that in a second there was a protest
over the weekend that showed pretty
deservedly I think just the level of
vitriol people after the mainstream
media we'll get to that in one second
first I've got to thank our friends over
at movement you know right now if you
are spending a lot of time in front of a
screen then you need to protect your
eyes I figured this out years ago and it
really really helps this is why the team
over at movement wants to make sure you
were taking care of your eyes with their
ever scroll blue light filtering glasses
crafted with special blue light lenses
movement ever scroll glasses protect
your eyes from digital eye strain and
other harmful effects from blue light
like headaches and poor sleep I know
you're probably thinking exactly what I
did when I first heard about this and
they go what the blue light is going to
affect me let's hit them some hippy
dippy stuff who cares then I tried
blocking
the blue light with things like these
glasses eat my eyes feel so much better
I actually do feel more restful at night
it's tremendous and movement gives you
quality protection and style the frames
are four movements best-selling fashion
hi were collections they look really
sharp movements just so good at that
they really really get style get 15% off
today with free shipping and returns go
to MVM t-dot-com slash knowles get the
ever squirrel solution better sleep
better focus better style go to MVM
t.com slash Knowles join the movement so
the great dispenser of red pills is the
mainstream media there was a protest
going on I think was in Long Island it
was about reopening New York and they
had a local journalist you know so it's
not even like CNN or ABC it's one of the
more local news channels but still a
left-wing news channel and they're going
around with the cameras and the people
protesting they're not having any of it
they're not being violent they're not
being threatening they just look at them
and they say hey you are fake news and
we're not going to pay any attention to
you you stopped airing the Trump
briefings that you keep airing Cuomo
briefings called
[Music]
we know you want to keep your job we get
it you're not getting used to Channel at
one time I love that guy at the end I
mean I love all these guys because
they're talking very blunt right this is
in Long Island this is in New York
people tend to be a little more blunt
over there they're not saying I'm gonna
kill you you're a terrible person no
they're just saying look your fake news
you're not doing your job
we know that you're telling lies now you
used to hide it better now you're not
hiding it so go home what do we need you
here for you're you're not covering the
news right now I guess that would be
your function er you're not doing that
you're just trying to harm us right
you're just trying to make us look bad
so get out of here we don't need you and
then that guy at the end he says you
used to be a pretty good news channel
what happened he's like he is it's such
a genuine sincere interaction with the
guys I used to watch you but you became
so transparently leftist the things you
were reporting are so different from
reality that I don't watch it go home we
don't need you Jim Acosta the the Ron
Burgundy of CNN tweets this out
he says disturbing no it's deserved it's
deserved if the mainstream media had
even continued to push their liberal
agenda which they've always had they've
had in this country for a long time but
they just didn't lie all the time they
just didn't go so far people would still
probably believe them but they couldn't
do it they could not do it and you know
the it's gotten more ridiculous and
egregious in the Trump era but the
mainstream media I've always had these
lives I mean Walter Durante one of the
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist New
York Times he covered the Soviet Union
and lied on behalf of the so V
Union it wasn't just that he got it
wrong he intentionally willfully lied
and covered up the crimes of the
Holodomor and famines in the Soviet
Union in the Western press because he
was a communist sympathizer and he
didn't care that much for the West and
he got a Pew let's surprise for it
Durante actually was noted where he was
actually the that he was the gay lover
of one of the most prolific occultist
and Satanists of the 20th century
Aleister Crowley that's a little it's
just a little side tidbit we don't need
to go into that too much shows you kind
of the corruption of some of these guys
though very you know these guys are
living radical lives and yet the
presentation Walter durante kulit
surprise winner mainstream media this is
the way it is all the news that's fit to
print then you find out no it's not all
the news that's fit to print it's all
the news that fits the narrative and all
these people and they're very serious
buttoned up coats and ties and they're
just giving you the facts maybe not
maybe they have an agenda maybe there
are pretty radical people actually so
the great example of these kind of lies
in in the Trump era even this weekend
one of the most hysterical and
sanctimonious reporters over at CNN is
Caitlin Collins Caitlin Collins has been
making herself the story now for weeks
she's been standing up to Trump she's
been harshly critical of Trump's motives
on the coronavirus response of his his
motives on even relationships to the
reporters so she's talking about
everyone's got to wear a mask right
she's got the mask on in the press
briefing room and she's given it to
Trump and it looks really good on TV
then the minute that the CNN cameras go
off do you know what she does she takes
off her mask luckily there was still
another camera going in the White House
briefing room so that the briefing ends
and then CNN cameras go off she goes
okay I don't need this mask anymore she
just takes it right off and she thinks
that we're not all gonna see that take a
look at this this is so if you can't if
you're not wife you're just listening
right now she's you know they finally
they all leave the room and some of the
reporters start to go and really really
bad stagecraft
caitlin collins stands up turns to face
the other cameras that are still there
it takes that mask off now she's trying
to spin it some people around her trying
to
and say oh she was getting ready to do a
television hit oh she was about to know
she takes it off before she even leaves
the room because none of these people
take their own what they're saying
seriously they're giving you those rube
masses one set of rules one set of
narratives and they're living by another
one themselves and and she wasn't even
the worst one at this at CNN
unfortunately Jake Tapper who some
conservatives say does a good job
sometimes he he was the most egregious
offender we'll get to that in one second
first though I've got to thank our
friends over at ready wise especially
now my friends having enough food to
last you in the event of a real food
emergency is sort of like life insurance
and it can save you and your loved ones
I used to be a little more loosey-goosey
about this you know I just didn't pay as
much attention to that kind of stuff and
then all of this happened and all of a
sudden it became a little bit more real
our sponsor wise company recently
changed their name to ready wise now it
is a better time than ever before
at least in recent memory to be prepared
with long-term nutritional food options
ready Wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition and new adventure meals for
hiking camping and other outdoor
activities it's not like you're always
waiting for the apocalypse sometimes
they're just good to have for any
situation where any wise meals are easy
to prepare you just add water they're
very long shelf life they make being
prepared simple and affordable they're
really really terrific this week my
listeners can get free shipping at ready
wise calm when entering Noel's kena wles
at checkout or by calling eight five
five four five three twenty nine
forty-five ready wise has a 90 day no
questions asked return policy there's no
risk taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family prepared today
that's ready wise re ad Y Wis EECOM
promo code Knowles to get free shipping
ok it wasn't just Caitlin Collins at CNN
it was also Jake Tapper so Jake Tapper
tweets this out quote President Trump
and his team are launching an unpressed
it's unprecedented smear campaign
against rivals levy leveling wild and
false allegations against critics in the
media and politics ranging from bizarre
conspiracy theories to spreading lies
about pedophilia and even murder
these smear campaigns are unmoored from
reality
they're deranged and indecent and seem
designed at least in part to distract us
from the horrific death health and
economic crisis caused by the pandemic
the pandemic which if impacts you is
what we will continue to focus on blah
blah blah so you know classic righteous
indignation Jake Tapper or even though
it's not particularly righteous
indignation what's he really saying with
all this vague language he's upset that
conservatives are going after Joe Biden
okay
he's he's upset that conservatives are
focusing on the allegations against Joe
Biden in the same way they focused on
the allegations against for instance
Brett Kavanaugh and frankly the
allegations against Joe Biden much much
much more credible than the allegations
against Kavanaugh talking about videos
going around of Joe like apparently
groping little girls I'm not you know
I'm not saying that any one of those
videos is the evidence that Joe is you
know Jeffrey Epstein himself I'm saying
that all of the videos are a little bit
weird and when you add them together
they show a pattern of behavior and if
those videos were of a Republican then
we would never hear the end of this from
people like Jake Tapper this is not a
pedophile conspiracy theory there are
lots of clips we you know we've seen all
the clips of Joe smelling all the
women's hair and the women and girls and
leaning in and feeling them and getting
a little creepy alright we don't need to
play the clip we played them on this
show a zillion times the one clip I will
play you though is is some evidence that
this has been a joke for many years not
just among conservatives and Republicans
also among liberals and Democrats Jon
Stewart did a whole riff about this back
when he was still running the The Daily
Show this would I guess would've been
about five years ago now four or five
years ago
where
Jon Stewart mocked gropey Joe you know
they put an image up of called The
Audacity of grope it was Joe Biden in
the very same memes that conservatives
are sending around now smelling a
woman's hair saying that it's actually a
senate rite of passage to have one of
the female members of your family
grabbed by Joe Biden that remorse about
lady touchin is the one thing Joe Biden
will not feel
[Applause]
and what could you possibly be saved her
[Laughter]
be still my child while I absorb your
precious lifes he's barely a senate rite
of passage not officially sworn in until
delaware jo has felt up one female
member of your immediately family you
know occasionally occasionally John
Stuart would take a shot at some
Democrat right and you know as mostly he
was taking shots at Republicans most of
them were unfair but occasionally he'd
take a shot at a left winger and a
Democrat too now you would never see
that happen now if you're even to play a
clip of John Stuart from 2015 then guys
like Jake Tapper will say that these
attacks are coming from President Trump
and his team Jon Stewart's not on
president Trump's team okay and I
guarantee you Jake Tapper saw clips like
that from Jon Stewart because the only
people who actually watched Jon Stewart
when his show was on the air were
members of the media because they were
within an echo chamber of their own
media narrative which increasingly
became divorced from reality the left
used to make fun of this back when Joe
Biden was just silly Uncle Joe he was VP
didn't really matter or before that he
was this kind of perennial candidate
right here not he ran in the 80s and he
ran in the two thousands they knew he
wanted to run again he's been in the
Senate for a long time he's kind of like
a nobody I actually think the first time
I ever saw Joe Biden on television was
on Jon Stewart's show and Jon Stewart
asked where are you gonna run for
president again and Joe Biden kind of
was coy about how he wanted to run and I
just thought this guy who is this guy
I've never even heard of him but he's
gonna run for president I don't think so
now though but now it's different
because Joe is going to be the nominee
so all of reality has to change
everything has to go upside down for the
narrative and I think a lot of people
are tuning that out Jake Tapper talks
about deranged conspiracy theories have
but I've got some deranged conspiracy
theories the Russia collusions
remember that remember when guys like
Jake Tapper including Jake Tapper told
us for years and years that Donald Trump
was some sort of Manchurian Candidate
from Moscow he colluded put in all these
Liberal Democrats like Adam Schiff who
lied about the evidence that they didn't
have for a Donald Trump collusion how
about remember the Moscow urine tape
there's you probably don't even remember
this because the the news cycle is so
rapid now but for years we were told
that there was a tape based on the steel
dossier which was funded by Democrats
which was then used by the Obama
administration to spy on on Hillary
Clinton's political rivals we were told
that Donald Trump was caught on tape
paying prostitutes in Russia to urinate
on his bed that was the image that all
the news channels charge completely fake
completely made-up and then of course
the most deranged conspiracy theory of
all promoted by Jake Tapper was the idea
that Brett Kavanaugh milk-toast federal
lawyer was actually secretly a gang
rapists with the whole mainstream media
perpetuated this one but especially Jake
Tapper there's now a third accuser the
lead starts right now
breaking news new horrific accusations
about Brett Cavanaugh's alleged behavior
with girls in high school Cavanaugh
denies it all he says the charges are
from the Twilight Zone
Michael avenatti who represents the
woman in question will be here in
minutes these new serious allegations
come just hours before Kavanagh and his
first accuser Christine Blasi Ford are
set to testify in front of the world
might these new charges derail that
hearing could they even sink his
confirmation could they I don't know
we're just asking questions I'm Jake
Tapper a serious journalist not like
those deranged conspiracy theorists who
those deranged conspiracy theorists or
playing videos of Joe Biden no no I'm
not like that
I'm just completely inventing stories
about a federal judge gang raping people
based on nothing Jake Tapper deranged
conspiracy theorists the media obviously
or I mean look we could we actually have
to move
because we because we didn't talk about
the media as an example of this for
probably six years straight never taking
a break and we wouldn't finish that's
the clearest example when you see what's
going on on television and you see
what's going on in real life with your
own two eyes
when you realize that those two things
are not the same then that's the
beginning of what Elon Musk might call a
red pill moment you also see it though
outside of the media you see it in law
and public advocacy a great example of
this is the ACLU there was a new policy
that came down from Betsy DeVos at the
Department of Education which is now
finally protecting the rights of the
accused on college campuses the accused
were having the due process rights
completely trampled by kangaroo courts
of leftist professors rather than you
know having even having these charges
brought up in the criminal justice
system Betsy DeVos changes that the ACLU
the American Civil Liberties Union comes
out swinging against the accused against
due process in favor of the narrative
we'll get to that in just one second
first I got to thank our friends over at
Express
VPN talking about your civil liberties
and privacy rights right now you're
probably online more than ever aren't
you I know I am hackers have all the
time in the world that is not a great
combination you've heard me talk about
how important it is to have a VPN I
don't go online without a VPN now that a
lot of you are working from home you're
gonna see why it matters so much to you
got to use the VPN that I trust which is
expressvpn it's the best VPN on the
market expressvpn doesn't log your data
that lots of really cheap or free VPNs
make money by selling your data and add
companies expressvpn developed
technology called trusted server makes
it impossible for their servers to log
any of your info speed or I've tried a
lot of VPNs a lot of them slow down your
connection they make it sluggish
expressvpn does not do that my internet
speeds are always blazing fast even when
I connect to servers thousands of miles
away I can stream HD quality videos with
the zero lag it's just really really
great you got to protect yourself online
use my link expressvpn calm slash
michael mi CH AE l use it today get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expressed
VPN comm / Michael expressvpn comm /
Michael and my sage ATL to learn more
Betsy DeVos comes out changes this rule
right so on college campuses we're told
what is it one in four girls is sexually
assaulted on campus makes basically
Harvard Yard more dangerous than
downtown Fallujah or something these
these numbers are based on on totally
cooked bogus statistics where the people
who were taking the surveys very
frequently will not realize that they've
been sexually assaulted based on the
criteria in the surveys so based on
those numbers there that we've been told
that you know we've got to trample over
the due process rights of the accused on
college campuses and instead of having
rape which is very obviously very
serious crime should be dealt with in
the criminal justice system instead of
having it treated seriously there it's
treated frivolously by panels of
professors and left-wing deans and
deputy assistant deputy deputy dean of
leftist inclusion and diversity on
campuses they just trample over the
these kids rights they will expel people
from school and when I say people I mean
boys because everyone's being accused
they will expel them from school without
any sort of due process so that
obviously you can't tolerate that and
frankly we shouldn't have professors
adjudicated questions of rape anyway
they're not qualified to do that they
don't have any any training to do that
so we should put this in the criminal
justice system Betsy the bus makes a few
tweaks to it to protect the rights of
the accused aclu furious divorce is
rolling back protections for sexual
harassment and assault survivors and
schools were suing to put a stop to it
so the ACLU is actually suing because
the Department of Education wants to
protect civil rights there are two
levels here some people look at that and
say wait a second this doesn't make any
sense because the ACLU is the American
Civil Liberties Union and sometimes in
the past they've protected civil
liberties so it's so wacky I can't
possibly understand why they would come
out against civil liberties that's one
level and then you get a little more red
pilled understanding and you realize
that the ACLU was never about
civil liberties it was always about
radical left ISM as explicitly it was
back communism the founder of the ACLU
Roger Baldwin was a communist he wrote a
book called liberty under the Soviets in
1928 he didn't write that ironically it
could sounds like it was a a precursor
to my blank book reasons to vote for
Democrats do you think of the the same
exact content reasons to vote for
Democrats and liberty under the Soviets
but it was a serious book making the
argument for liberty under under that
communist regime in 1943 the California
Committee on on American activities said
that the ACLU quote may be definitely
classed as a communist front at least 90
percent of the efforts of the ACLU early
on and perhaps even since then have been
expended on behalf of communists who
come into conflict with the law the
Daily Worker the Communist newspaper
wrote glowingly about the ACLU early on
okay the thing wasn't what it said it
was the news isn't the news and the ACLU
isn't about civil liberties it's just
about radical left ISM when you realize
that and it starts to make sense
the ACLU came out strongly against Brett
Kavanaugh and trampling his civil
liberties on behalf of unsubstantiated
allegations and they're doing it again
now it's fine we can either you know
express shock and indignation over this
for months and months and years and
years or we can realize that that thing
is corrupt intrinsically and ignore it
rip it down do something else it's not
just even in legal advocacy we're seeing
this kind of red pilling in education
and we're seeing president Trump pushing
back against it we'll get to that in one
second first though I've got to thank
you I've got to thank you one for you
know becoming members at Daily wire also
thank you for subscribing to my youtube
channel
not just the daily why our YouTube
channel but the Michael nul show YouTube
channel I didn't even realize really
that I had a YouTube channel somebody
else made it I guess you know and they
but no one was really paying any
attention to it and so we've started
putting some breakout segments and some
exclusive interviews and some bonus
stories on there that we didn't get to
during the show and now a lot of people
are going over and joining so head on
over to that Michael Nolt show YouTube
channel click Subscribe also I got some
great news
remember we were selling no we're not
selling we were giving away to leftist
ears tumblers a little while back now
we're bringing back the two tumblers but
it's only available for our most
exclusive membership tier all access the
all access membership tier is the
premier level of membership all meant
all access members get to participate in
all access live our brand-new
interactive programming featuring one of
us as we hang out with you each night
which 99.9% of the time goes great
except the last time I tried to do it
but the Internet my neighborhood
completely crapped out but other than
that it goes over great it's been a lot
of fun you get Q&A discussions available
both on the website and the daily wire
app now you get not just one but where's
my second one I guess we already gave it
away oh no here it is you get both of
the leftist tiers tumblers and you my
friends are going to need it because the
the red pills are flowing and that the
when the Elon Musk red pills start
flowing then the natural consequence
every action has a an equal and opposite
reaction I learned that from you know
kind of really brilliant engineer guys
like Elon Musk the opposite reaction is
filling up the leftist tears go to Delhi
where calm we'll be right back with a
lot more
you see the red pilling in the media you
see the red pill in legal advocacy
you're also seeing it in education
homeschooling has become very popular in
recent years much much more popular than
in past years school choice has become
more popular people want to break out of
this monopoly of government education
and as that that is happening the
government is trying to take more and
more power so even if they can't expand
the percentage of kids that they're
getting they want to expand the timeline
so for instance when I was you know when
my father was a kid you didn't have to
go to kindergarten that was kind of a
new thing and we're so he just went
straight to first grade then when I was
a kid you had kindergarten but I didn't
go to the like preschool or anything
like that and now kids go to preschool
at age 4 or age 3 I've even heard of
people sending their two-year-olds to
preschool right so you extend the amount
of time that the government gets with
your kids and that even if it's private
preschool that the the kind of liberal
apparatus gets with your kids then now
they want everybody to go to college
even if they're gonna go away into debt
even if they're going to get a worthless
degree that deprives them both of
education and job prospects they just
want to keep you in those instant that
that state liberal institution longer
obviously in kovat people are gonna have
to start homeschooling and harvard is
having none of it the elite academic
apparatus is trying to shut down
homeschooling you heard from this woman
Elizabeth Barthel it she's a Harvard Law
School professor she came out and
basically said she wants homeschooling
band now she's got another article this
was published in the Harvard Gazette a
warning on homeschooling nationally
renowned child welfare expert Elizabeth
Barth Allah you know how great those
experts are we've been talking about
them a lot on the show in the last few
weeks those experts you can't question
them so so I don't know what it is that
makes her an expert but that the Harvard
says she's an expert so she is she wants
to see a radical transformation in home
school she argues that the lack of
regulation in the home schooling system
poses a threat to children in society so
we got to shut it down two points she
makes on homeschooling both of one is
more laughable than the next she says
behind the rapid growth of the
homeschooling movement is the growth in
the conservative evangelical movement
dun-dun-dun not those evangelicals not
those conservatives conservative
Christians wanted the chance to bring
their children up with their values and
belief systems and saw a home schooling
is a way to escape from the secular
education in public schools yeah well no
it's not a way to escape from secular
education because the secular education
is all around us in the culture in the
government in the law in everywhere
right but it's a way to have an
alternative so you're gonna get
bombarded with secular liberalism all
day long but maybe you can get a little
bit of an alternative in homeschool they
fought the battle with public school
systems to have their children exempted
from exposure to alternative values in
the schools and lost that part she gets
completely backwards the whole reason
for homeschooling is to show children an
alternative this apparatus of media and
legal advocacy and education and
Hollywood and everything together that
is the monolithic liberal secular
culture that you're being bombarded with
24/7 so going to church which they're
not allowing us to do right now and
they're exploiting kovat as a reason to
shut down churches and arrest pastors or
doing homeschooling which they don't
want to allow us to do some of the great
legal child welfare education experts
want to ban that sort of thing that
would be the alternative and yet they
don't want an alternative they don't
want any competition to their system to
their narrative they don't want you to
take the red pill so the Gazette asks
this professor Bartlett could you
compare the homeschooling phenomenon in
the u.s. to other countries and here's
the part where you you can't even
believe that they're this unselfish
because if we look at what goes on in
other countries the u.s. stands out as
an anomaly when other countries allow
homeschooling they regulate it much more
strictly they demand that parents show
they are qualified to teach and that
they turn in the curricula they plan to
use to the state so these other
countries they basically make
homeschooling just a facet of the state
so it really
can't really provide an authentically
alternative possibility toward the kind
of shallow leftist education that people
are getting now because the state's got
to sign off on it and then here's the
money lot they also mandate that the
homeschooling curriculum provides an
education equivalent to public school
and includes teaching about the
fundamental values of our society some
countries like Germany effectively ban
homeschooling altogether in the u.s.
there is essentially no effective
regulation so I'm a little bit of a
history buff you know and I got friends
in Germany I've quite a bit of respect
for some elements of German culture but
Germany's got a little bit of a
checkered past you know on history and
everything so whenever I see Germany did
it and that's why we should do it too I
just at Google you know I just want to
double check okay so I googled and I try
to figure out when did Germany
effectively ban homeschooling altogether
under what notoriously mustachioed
regime with that screaming guy did they
ban homeschooling and yeah you guessed
it it would be it would be the Nazis so
so the left think of it that perverse
this is when a guy like Elon Musk says
hey I'm taking the red pill I'm
questioning the official narrative I'm
thinking of alternative ways to envision
society and education in life when you
say that that they call you a Nazi but
when you explicitly endorse Nazi
policies and and admit that their Nazi
policies you say I want to do what the
Germans did in the 30s but then you're
not a Nazi then you're a good wonderful
liberal open-minded person and and they
won't get called out for it because
because the education is so weak even in
places like Harvard which was once one
of the top universities in the country
that's the you know and by the way it'd
be one thing if the education that
people were getting were a decent
education but it's not we know that it's
not
we know that it's shallow that they're
hollowing out the educational system
that was the cause for the rise of
homeschooling in the first place so
what's the red pill the news isn't the
news the ACLU isn't for civil liberties
education isn't about education the
ideological system that we are living in
is corrupt it's really really really
corrupt it's transparently corrupt its
decadently corrupt so when the system is
basically working when it's relatively
honest we can play by the rules we kind
of go along with it even though we think
Walter Cronkite's kind of a big Lib we
just go along with it we all go along to
get along we can be nice we can be
polite we can be genial when the system
becomes too corrupt to transparently
dishonest then we need to stop playing
by the rules and that's what Trump does
and that's why Trump I guess in a in a
certain sense is the great dispenser of
the so-called red pills because Donald
Trump he does not he doesn't play like a
Democrat and he doesn't play like a
Republican used to play back when we all
just went along to get along and were
nice and genial and Republicans would
lose a little bit more slowly than they
would have lost otherwise Trump doesn't
do that Trump Trump you know is now
pursuing through the Department of
Justice so here you know in the
executive branch through the Department
of Justice they are pursuing all these
crimes that took place at the end of
2016 at the end of the Obama
administration things like the unmasking
of Michael Flynn things like spying
illegal spying on the Trump campaign all
of these shenanigans in the deep State
Obama's coming out swinging because I
think Obama thinks that the best defense
sometimes is a good offense and he's
really nervous at that all of the trails
point back to Barack Obama knowing about
a lot of these nefarious unprecedented
possibly criminal activities so Obama's
going really hard after Trump you know
in the old days the president would
refrain from criticizing his successor
that's what Bush did
Bush refrained from criticizing Obama
they although they played along really
nice but that's not what happens when it
comes to Trump mr. Trump is actually
threatening their corrupt ideological
system
so Obama goes yelling he's saying all
awful things about Trump in the genial
nice in the old way in the sort of Bush
administration way they wouldn't have
come out swinging they'd say well
brought mr. Obama has his opinion we
have ours but they wouldn't come out
swinging they asked Donald Trump about
this he goes yeah Obama's totally
incompetent that's just the way he is
look he was an incompetent president
that's all I can say grossly incompetent
thank you it's the full statement I'd
like to make a full statement he's a
he's completely incompetent thank you
very much and then he walks away people
are shocked they clutch their pearls on
the left and the right that's not how
presidents are supposed to talk about
other presidents well but Barack Obama
started it didn't he
Barack Obama started this fight because
he's getting a little nervous because of
the investigations into his wrongdoing
but according to the old system of rules
the Republicans are supposed to just
hang back oh it's okay look the yeah the
media is unfair to us yeah you know the
ACLU is unfair to us yeah the education
system is unfair to us
yeah Hollywood's unfair to us yeah the
bureaucracy is unfair to us but hey
that's just that's just the system and
we wouldn't want to be impolite so I
guess we just got to go along with it
you can only push that so far you can
only tolerate that tension between the
official narrative and the reality so
far before you say no we're just gonna
reject it we're done with that
what's your response then you know that
what the press was waiting for was some
kind of really nuanced statement from
Trump and he's gonna resist attacking
Obama and know you just know yeah Obama
is incompetent you should have added the
word corrupt to that and we're we're not
gonna play by those rules anymore James
Woods great actor great political
observer he tweeted at this observation
let's face it Donald Trump is a rough
individual he is vain insensitive and
raw but he loves America more than any
president my lifetime he's the last
firewall between us in this cesspool
called Washington
I'll take him any day over any of these
bumps Trump 2020 and Trump tweets it he
retweets it he goes I think that is a
great compliment thank you James James
also insulted him here in the city's
vain insensitive and raw right so at you
know there's this story there's this
idea that that Donald Trump is
he's a hair-trigger he's so sensitive
that he's gonna you know if you say any
even remote criticism of him he's gonna
lash out at you know in this tweet James
Woods did criticize him
call somebody vain is a you know that's
that is actually a harsh criticism but I
don't I don't I think Trump actually has
in a way a sort of humility I mean he's
joked about this a few times I remember
famously he was asked about drinking
beer he said I'm the only president
who's never had a beer it's the only
good thing you can say about me could
you imagine if I drank beer all I'd be
the worst if I was a drunk you know any
it's that does show a little
self-awareness to say the only good
thing you can say about me is I don't
drink beer he Trump knows who he is you
knows what kind of guy he is he knows
that in normal times when we're all
playing Jeannie Lee by the system there
is no Trump right don't forget Trump has
been interested in being president since
the 80s but the times were not ready for
Trump in the 80s or the 90s or even in
the 2000s he threatened to run for
president a few times in the 80s and in
2000 and 2012 but then this is the
moment this is that red pill moment
where people say okay all the nice
nuanced subtlety charm you know Marquess
of Queensbury rules that we all played
by Trump can't win in that in that
situation but now we're past that now
that difference is between the reality
and the illusion has gotten so big that
we're ready for a guy like Trump and a
great counter example to this is Justin
Amash you know Justin Amash is probably
not he's this former Republican
congressman who got his feelings hurt by
Donald Trump and so he left the
Republican Party he's the only one who
voted for you know impeachment that sort
of thing but he's not a Republican so
doesn't really count you know Amash said
he was gonna run for president he wanted
to run for president on the Libertarian
Party ticket and he was so excited cuz
he's gonna take down Trump it's the most
important thing to take down Trump he
only announced this a few weeks ago now
he's already ending his campaign what
happened here's the here's what the
quote thanks for your support as I've
been exploring a run for president as a
potential nominee of the libertarian
party I've spent you
only three decades or thirty three
decades three weeks assessing the race
appearing in media talking to delegates
and donors watching the libertarian
party's convention plan unfold and
gathering feedback from family friends
and other advisers after much reflection
I've concluded that circumstances don't
lend themselves to my success as a
candidate for president this year
therefore I will not be a candidate
pause there for one second if it
requires you much reflection to realize
that the Libertarian Party candidate for
president isn't gonna win whoever the
candidate is then that you're probably
farther gone than and you thought you
might need a whole lot of reflection on
a whole lot of other things that you're
thinking he goes on this was a difficult
decision for me especially having seen
grassroots supporters put so much effort
into this campaign pause there again
Justin Amash does not have a single
grassroots supporter not one he has like
old weekly standard guys like a couple
of them who were really upset at how
much they hate Trump pushing him to run
he does not he does not have a
grassroots supporter okay it's been
humbling and awesome Justin Amash
wouldn't call him a humble guy but Joe
that's just from what I see on TV today
most Americans are understandably more
interested in what life will look like
tomorrow than they are in broader policy
debates and news coverage has reflected
these priorities at the same time
fundraising challenges posed by an adult
economy will hinder advertising so that
I actually think that the money line
you're the most important line to look
at is that last one it's not all the BS
about all people really wanted me to run
and I I was really gonna become
president until you know I guess I won't
but but I was close I was the man who
was almost president that line there at
the end
today most Americans are more interested
in what life will look like tomorrow
than they are in broader policy debates
and so I therefore I won't run is to say
that my campaign is a joke and when when
everything is perfectly fine and we all
have the luxury and the decadence to
think about stupid nonsense like the
Justin Amash presidential campaign then
I really stand a chance then I should
really run but during real times when
people have real problems then I
certainly can't run
and that is Justin Amash style
conservatism and even more damning the
other reason he's not running there were
a lot of people actually some of the old
Weekly Standard people and some of the
hardcore remaining never Trump errs who
that they were the people who would have
liked Justin Amash as a candidate but
they actually came out against him once
he said he might run because they said
he might help reelect Trump
they thought that Amash would not take
votes away from Donald Trump
not a single tumble from supporter was
gonna vote for that guy not a chance but
he might take votes away from Joe Biden
because Joe Biden is this completely
desiccated declining doddering guy who
was not impressive even when he was with
it and who now has these you know kind
of creepy allegations against him so
they might vote for Amash that might
help Trump win and so Justin Amash who
would have called himself pro liberty
pro free 'dom probably would called him
he would have counted himself on the
right even just a few weeks ago the the
proximate urgent reason why he dropped
out of the race is because he might hurt
the left wing candidate and help the
genuinely right wing candidate that is
some weak sauce all right and that that
is the difference between the red pill
and the blue pill the red pill is Trump
and the blue pill is Justin Amash you
know the sort of genial loser who exists
specifically not to upset the liberal
ideological system okay and the red pill
is shaking that up and very basically
saying I don't believe what I'm seeing
on TV I don't believe what I'm being
told and the proof of this of course is
that the minute you even mention
questioning the narrative you use a
phrase like the red pill all of a sudden
the the mainstream media the one who
wants you to believe their narrative
they're saying hey look some Nazi once
used the phrase blue pill so you're a
Nazi don't question us listen to what
we're saying 24/7 even if it's even if
it's not true well sorry guys I think
the genies out of the bottle and I don't
think it's just hardcore conservatives
who
who are recognizing the lies of that
leftist ideology
I think it's guys like Elon Musk who
might now move his business it's
actually out of California because of
those leftist policies I think it's guys
like Joe Rogan I think it's a lot of
people who are more in the middle who
are a little more independent they're
beginning to wake up to that and that is
a wonderful thing
gosh those pills go down great don't
they that's our show got a lot more to
get to we'll do it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see you then the
Michael Noel's show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen